there's a pencil right that's all i need
is a pencil a piece of paper would come
in handy and i'm going to write some
dialogue
and it's going to take place in one
place with two chairs
and that's all i need
[Music]
how do you teach people about drama you
cannot learn how to write drama without
writing plays putting it on in front of
an audience and getting humiliated
hemingway said writing is easy all you
got to do is sit down with the
typewriter and bleed
throw away all the distractions and
write something every plane he's ever
beginning middle and an end
jean lucadas said not necessarily in
that order and that's why french movies
are so effing boring
the rules to me are very very simple
your job is to tell
a story a story has a hero and he or she
wants
one thing if it doesn't tend toward the
punch line take it out
gossip is just creating dialogue millie
says to him blah blah blah bob said
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
that's as good as dialogue as anybody
else can write
i would hope that you guys would be
encouraged to say if this class clown
can do so well hell i'll try it too
i'm not any less confused than you are
i just got in the habit of doing it
we all have ideas all the time our mind
is a raging fire at some point you're
going to say okay
it's going to be bad you got to stand
being bad
if you want to be a writer because if
you don't you're never gonna write
anything good
we're given a great gift and a great
responsibility which is to tell stories
as honestly as we can
and experience things in the process
that are beautiful
david mamet and this is my master class
you